we're about to go live
do it we're already live david just say
it
we're officially live episode 73
with seven time mr x mr olympia uh
phil heath we got adam sauce and we got
gerard
michaels aka former boy scout right oh
yes or no you always be prepared and by
the way he was as well for a day
so you you have to be a part of it if
you were now in iran we never had boy
scouts i can't say boy scouts it was a
very different situation to be in boy
scouts in iran yeah you were never a
part of it
never so we got some things to talk
about with boise folks there's a lot of
stuff going on today with topics we got
an 850 million dollar settlement with
tens of thousands of sexual abuse
victims for boy scouts we'll cover that
nike responds to shikari richardson's
one-month suspension for positive
marijuana this will cover that
nike is a brand of china and 4chan brand
of china fortune did we discuss this
last time kai or now
i think we ought to cover that because
xi gave a speech
on their 100-year anniversary did you
read this speech i did
we got it covered on cnn have you read
this speech on what he said
no you're ready okay we'll go through
that but i thought it was interesting
joe rogan is apparently the leader of
cancel culture according to carlos
mencia
which you're probably going to have some
opinions on that both of you haven't
been in the comedy world for
a while uh we have iggy uh uh
zelia blackfish music video scandal
explained i guess we'll see what that's
all about
why don't rich people pay cash for homes
dustin poitier
and conor mcgregor major major
prediction that's going to be made here
that uh you know you may or may not
believe this is not financial advice
it's not college athletes finally are
able to start making money
and then 130 nations agreed to support
u.s proposal for global minimum tax on
corporations i know that's probably not
a crazy topic
for maybe you but it is a topic i want
to talk about i got to tell you a pretty
big time
this is massive massive i knew you would
have strong opinions
yeah it's massive to talk about so
anyways how was your weekend
you know your your weekend your saturday
your fourth of july i mean
can we just give a shout out to you we
had a great time at your house that's
awesome
gerard barbecue was so good we ate it
yesterday we had some leftovers
yesterday you heard about the dream
crush that would barbecue you heard
about the drama though here we go
because
who's usually barbecuing at the pbd
barbecues leo leo yeah
but then who shows up like coming out of
the top rope just i'm the meat man now
gerard says
i'm here grilling listen the fact that
this is not the first time adam's had
two men's beating his mouth
so i mean you know we're just trying to
make sure speaking of boys
i'm just trying to make you comfortable
yeah gerard and leo got into a heated
meat debate over the meat steak
we all wanted our meat in adam's mouth
it was so we just had to split the green
one is the question though who wanted it
it worked out well he handled the
chicken i handled the steak it was you
know everybody was
it was ebony and ivory all right
listen if you if you missed it like 20
minutes prior to us going live today
adam and gerard had to be separated
it was pretty ugly yeah well thank god
we got people shots were being fired
adam took a swing and then gerard kicked
and then we just said let's settle this
on the podcast yeah he can't throw this
the soy man the sewing man mafia has
been coming after me in the comments so
i gotta you know i gotta
you're getting it i got it i got it yeah
we got phil here
meet kevin on having kevin on with us
who's running for governor which by the
way if everybody's listening to this i
don't know if you know or not i gave him
twenty five hundred dollars to his
campaign yeah for the
california underground occupation he's a
democrat he's running a guy give him 2
for his campaign because uh and him and
i had a conversation together afterwards
and uh he uh uh took up the challenge
and we're gonna wait probably next month
or two we may bring them back on to
address some of the concerns that was
brought up by the audience see how he
handles it but i think this guy's got a
big upside
how'd you think he did how did you think
he did meet kevin
i'll let them go first nobody you were
you was in front of you he was watching
it
listen man uh meet kevin is very very
passionate i'll give him that
he's very passionate he wants california
to succeed he wants california to be
better
but um he's an ideologue and this is
honestly a problem i have
with most people on the quote-unquote
left today they
they think their good intentions
supersede their bad ideas
right so the idea of what we're gonna do
is we're going to
friendly put in sending the national
guard to kindly
round up uh
yeah the unwanted people on our streets
and we're going to put them in these
awesome super not re-education detention
camps where they're going to get the
education that they need and the help
that they need and we're just going to
you know
because listen man if people that were
in this situation
were capable of functioning at that sort
of level now i'm not saying that
it's not a noble idea what i'm saying is
is that rounding up the people you don't
want
and putting them into a camp has been
tried before and it didn't work out yeah
so is that the only thing you took from
his two-hour
sit down here no like that one thing or
what else would i no because he also
wants to put uh
local governments under occupation as
well so it was all negative stuff there
was nothing you agreed with it was all
just ideologue that i don't agree with
i think that what happens is that listen
if you're going to sit here and have a
conversation with me you're so friendly
today what is the story
what happened over the weekend after the
show you want to have a conversation
with me about the way
you think things should be and you want
to be you know
uh some sort of a utopian ideologue
that's fine that's your that's your
prerogative as as a person okay i wish
we can do x
if you're running for governor of the
fourth largest economy in the freaking
world
and your idea is to send in the national
guard and round up the people i don't
want on my streets
i'm sorry but you have to have some
pushback and it should have frankly
it's not about him there should have
been somebody in his camp that was like
okay you understand how this is going to
sound to anybody
that believes in in the cobra paradox at
all like in the promise i don't even
know if he has a camp i think he's like
kind of doing it solo
guys this is not like a kid you're going
to like high five like you're doing
great speaking on stage
bloody freaking government of california
you had strong opinions
on him too i think that was the problem
and most importantly
he's the type that probably has done
very well rehearsed
but when he comes into maybe like a road
game hostile situation
with it really wasn't even hostile which
i give him credit for right
in fairness but to me that's an
opportunity right and i think he missed
it because
he did get pushed back and
kind of deflected a lot and couldn't get
to the point and i think
one of the things that i've noticed like
here when we talk about politics or
business
is a running mate people the
partnerships that he has
this guy has a ton of things going on
you know in his life but he didn't once
mention like
who would help put these people in these
places
that requires a lot of funding a lot of
money he didn't walk us through those
things
and that's what i was most concerned
with and then when pat would ask
about that it was more like well i don't
have all the answers but then he had all
the answers
i have all the answers and i don't
really i need the data
so that's where i got kind of confused
as to okay you you're a know-it-all but
you don't know any here's what i will
tell you about this here's what i would
tell you about this
roger stone okay people ask me and say
why do you interview all these random
people you know like all these mobsters
roger stone
former criminals all these people right
because everything's about how did it
get you to
be thinking the way you think right
roger stone is a pretty
pretty weird guy and when he was talking
he said a few different things he said
in life everybody goes through three
phases he says first phase is
who is roger stone like meaning who's
roger stone
second phase is get me roger stone
third phase is i need somebody like
roger stone fourth phase is
who's roger stone meaning you're
forgotten about right you start off with
you're for nobody knows who you are
irrelevant then you go to dude this
guy's amazing i want him then you go to
get me somebody like him that's younger
then you go to i have no i've never
heard of them before right okay
i don't care what anybody says agree or
disagree with this guy the level of
respect i got for
people like me kevin you go build a 2
million subscriber channel at 28 29
years old and get that kind of an
audience in money real estate
making 6.2 million dollars in a year at
that age
he's absolutely crushing it this is the
biggest thing with a guy like that
i've been running sales teams for a long
time the biggest thing with a guy like
that
at that point sometimes when you win
very early
one of the hardest things for you to do
is to listen to anybody
it's the hardest thing to do when you
win early when you win
later after you've lost anything
everything it's one of the best things
that have happened to you
it typically ends up becoming a better
person to be a leader
when you lost everything in your 20s i'm
talking
girl money fame success you were the
main guy you got your nose bloody
all of that 20s and 30s when it happens
then you lead in your 40s and 50s
now you're kind of like remember listen
you know everybody gets knocked out hey
listen yeah as bad as you are everybody
go so i think he hasn't gone through
that yet which is my recommendation too
was to go get
his nose bloody and then the other part
is you need a couple guys like them
behind closed doors
yeah you need a couple guys like them to
talk to me on closer that's going to be
like yeah i don't know about that i
don't know how it's going to work
push back push back push back and then
for him to argue with you and say no
here's why i believe in this
and he's still going to push back and
he's going to say you know what no i get
the point
kind of like yesterday watching the you
know at the house and you see there's
pushback
and then finally he's like yeah okay i
agree that's fine i totally understand i
think there needs to be a little bit of
that
we're going to see what's going to
happen with him i i hope the guy's got a
big upset he doesn't slow down and i
hope this doesn't discourage him to go
run
right but uh it is what it is let me get
you guys opinion on something because
you know right after the podcast who was
on ricky with you guys
yes and then you popped in oh no that
was the one time
so right after the podcast i interviewed
him yeah and it was more of a financial
type interview it wasn't that i even
said we're not going to be political all
we talk is money all we talk is money
we did the financial interview but i
said let me ask you something kevin
respect you came
on you know you did your thing
have you ever been a a mayor
a representative a dog catcher like if
you've never been in politics
ever what makes you think a lack of
experience is a good thing meaning
you've done real estate for 10 years
i've never done real estate i've done
finance
yeah but i've never done real estate
that's like me saying i think i'm gonna
be a realtor today
and the number one realtor in the entire
state what makes you think
that you can just be governor with zero
experience and i think
this is what i would have called the dj
djt effect donald j
trump is that look he became president
with zero experience but the guy's been
in the media the guy's been in
yeah for 40 years he's been in the
political game
but my point is this trump made it
acceptable for anyone to say all right
[ __ ] it i'm giving it a shot
whatever it may be whereas i think like
pat said respect
to getting out there and think you could
do your thing but if you have zero
experience i can't believe i'm going to
say this but
adam that's a good point um
it happens more often yeah let that go
through your head a little bit anyway
johnny cash yeah but you got to cut that
short clip
to you just cut that up for me to your
credit man and your point the whole time
he was sitting there and i actually said
it
later on the interview because i didn't
want to hammer the guy but i i have been
in politics and i was i wasn't
in on the other side of it you literally
wrote speeches for chris christie
yes yes so now they do thank you for
that yeah but the
yeah but the the the side i'm i'm trying
to say is is that the whole time and i
waited two hours
and then he finally went on the
offensive and i actually pointed to him
i was like congratulations you finally
went on the offensive
and i texted pat afterwards because you
were talking about giving you know he he
needs a little he needs encouragement
and he does have a bright future and i
said well if he
if he's going to do this and he he's
going to make drastic changes like that
he has to make it
about the opponent so anytime anybody if
you're ever thinking about running for
politics you get this one for free
this is the value entertainment all
right all he had to do
at any moment and he still didn't do it
in in the video that he did in response
he had to admit that what he was saying
was
outrageous but these are outrageous
times there you go that's all he had to
do
he had to say listen i don't want to put
california under occupation
but it's a state of emergency gavin
newsom screwed up
so bad for so long that we have to treat
this
as the emergency that it is take it off
of him
put it on gavin newsom treat it as
something that's temporary in a response
to bad administration that he has to
come and i don't want to do this
i don't want to do this now you have
libertarians like me republicans
like other people saying this is an
overreach of government but at least
it's temporary and at least he
he knows that it's bad now it could be
bs
everything that the government does
that's temporary the the federal income
tax was temporary measure 100 years
later we're still here right
so we all know that in the back of our
head and that's why we give pushback we
know that you're taking this power and
you're never giving it back
now the other side who wants to hear the
utopian butterflies and the hell yeah
we're gonna we're gonna heal all the
homeless we're
they've been trying to do it for ten
thousand years but i got this plan and
this plan is we're gonna round them up
and throw them somewhere else where you
don't see them
dude now the wild thing the craziest
part about this was rudy giuliani
in the sit-down that you had with him
literally said the first thing you have
to do is clean up the streets you have
to get rid of the homeless
it's the very first thing rudy said he
said you can you can lower
in the interview with you he said you
can lower murders by 90
but nobody ever sees a murder so they
won't believe crime is going down unless
you get rid of the graffiti and you
clean up the homeless he said until i
got rid of the squeegee guys
nobody believed new york had a
turnaround right so in that time he's
he his methodology isn't necessarily
wrong
his messaging really really is and and
that's where it's great feedback for him
that's great feedback and by the way
knowing him he's probably listening
someone's going to tell him about this
he's going to listen to this
and hopefully he'll take that feedback
anyways okay so let's get right into it
with different things that we got going
on
i say we start off with nike response to
shikari richardson's one-month
suspension for positive
marijuana tests go to page five of the
story that came out it's been all over
the place
er you know uh let me see this here okay
so shikari richardson accepted a
one-month suspension after testing
positive for marijuana usada announced
since the tournament the fan favorite
athlete has apologized richardson 21 a
minute that she used marijuana
after finding out her biological mother
died from a report
from a reporter prior to competing in
olympic trials nike the brand that
sponsored richardson responded we
appreciate shikari shikari's honesty
and accountability and we will continue
to support her through this time
the company said in a statement on june
19 shikari punched her ticket for tokyo
olympics with a dominant one at the u.s
olympic track and field trials
in oregon the athlete recorded a time of
10.86 seconds
in 100 meter race earning a spot on her
first ever olympic team usada revealed
in the statement that richardson results
on june 19 which included
includes her olympic qualifying results
have been disqualified gerard
oh my god listen we are living in a
bizarro time man we are living in the
craziest times of all time
where somebody who smokes weed can't
compete but a biological man can compete
against women and that's not a problem
at all
that's not that's nobody nobody has
anything to say about that where a
biological man can can go weight lift
against women
no issue whatsoever okay but somebody
smokes a little bit of weed
all right in in in probably a state
where it's completely legal now
and they can't represent their country
like it's outrageous
to me on the left the levels of
hypocrisy
that are in our beer our bureaucratic
systems right now are insane
they're insane to me now if if you are
able to run 100 meters
in under 11 seconds while you're high
giving her an extra medal give her a
green medal
are you kidding me like all i i don't
smoke weed because i don't need
any uh motivation well the state lazy
slows you down
yeah complete obviously you know what
i'm saying i smoke weed i'm eating
cookies i'm not running a hundred meters
you know what i'm saying like dude
this is crazy by the way by the way let
me ask you this but the idea that they
suspended her for a month
good bad bad growing up why though why
is it bad
why is it bad what what is the what is
the object of it is the object to be a
deterrent for children
like what what let me ask you this let
me ask you a question so you know the
whole thing with reggie bush how
it's like now i deserve my heisman back
because of what you did now it's legal
so you should give it back to me right
at the time when he did it
it was illegal how does the law work i
agree with what i'm asking you is
at the time when you did it that was a
law you broke right so prohibition used
to be illegal if you did it
at that time you went to jail so people
finally said listen this is a terrible
idea man
we cannot be doing this so is it
something where you did break the law
we have to keep it or else because
someone in the future is going to come
back and say
you let shakari down you know you let
her get away with it what's
what's wrong with what i'm doing what's
the difference between me using steroids
and her use
smoking marijuana both of them were
illegal at the same time the problem
is is that she's supposed to be able to
run on the relay team
and to me it's like well if she can run
on the relay team
why not the 100 meters so i went on
twitter and i asked and a lot of people
said well
it's the timing of the one month
suspension and i thought well to me that
doesn't make any sense
it should be all or nothing you know
like she's going to
do well at the relay we already know
that but to me she should be able to run
in 100 meters maybe she was just
training passing the duchy bro like
she was just trying to get the old relay
at the other day i gave her mad props
for actually showing accountability
and actually saying why she was doing it
in the first place my biggest
issue is who was in her camp prior to
this there has to be some handler that
says okay
she's going through this this and this
you're going to be tested around this
time
like who doesn't know the freaking
testing schedule so that you can give
the ioc a heads up
hey we have this is there a way that
we could write an exemption because of
why she was doing it it was prescribed
or whatever it is
but for them to just say you got pop
this and that is like who are handling
these athletes
you got to be better about this because
now she's not going to be able to
entertain
yeah not be able to represent the
country in that event that we were all
in shock over you know her performance
now it's even crazier
you're still a high level competitor i i
competed everybody here knows people
that competed right
they have no problem pumping us full of
drugs
full of drugs right like i played an
entire season
getting shots in my shoulder every like
i couldn't
i could not i was an all-star in 2009 i
could not wash my hair after the games
you're supposed to take like 100
milligrams of celebrities a day i was up
to a thousand milligrams by freaking
by by uh by batting practice man i'm
getting shots in my shoulder once a
month
and you know my body's just shutting
down but i'm playing well and in that
level if you're not on the field
somebody's taking your job
you know what i'm saying so like if she
blew her hamstring out they would have
no problem whatsoever injecting her with
a chemical cocktail
like no problem whatsoever and that
would be okay yeah right but she smokes
weed and it's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa then where's the
person who
look like we talk about the nba and
other athletes being able to do this now
right
where's the person that coming up for
the olympics that says you know what in
basketball they're not really testing
for this
and i'm sure they're not testing the nba
guys that are going to be traveling for
the olympic team
i would be smartest thing david stern
ever did right so
so what baseball did with their testing
was like yeah we're not doing right so
are we testing the nba guys
who by the way who suspended or usada
suspended or right yeah
so it's not what is it what is that yeah
usada and you have water those those are
the two different what do they stand for
what is usada stanford
world anti-doping agency isa and they
they're supposed to handle
yeah now there's now what's crazy about
wada i think that this is like one of
the lesser-known things everybody uh
hates on uh
lance armstrong they did retroactive
testing once they found out that that
you know these guys were you know
isotope testing so what people don't
know lance armstrong with the livestrong
right
yeah he the biggest cheater of all time
this guy let america down how dare he
if i'm now i could be wrong because i'm
going outside my head but if i remember
correctly
when they did retroactive testing on
lance armstrong you would have had to
have gone to like 27th or 28th
place in the tour de france before
defaults before you found somebody
who didn't have uh extra levels of the
top 25 people who are doing an elite
they were all he did so he he got caught
he wasn't just lance he was juicing
better than the rest of them so here's
the question though
does reggie bush deserve his heisman
back uh i don't
i don't think so no okay i don't think
so why well because
usc was playing under different rules
than the other competition
i don't think smoking marijuana gives
you an advantage over the competition i
think paying
players for recruiting the best talent
when your other people aren't does give
you an advantage over the competition
i think that one isn't the same as the
other in that regard i i actually agree
with you about reggie bush i think
reggie bush just has to wear it i
don't think it's right that the player's
gonna get paid but he has to wear it and
what you're talking about goes back to
like
it's the laws of man versus the laws of
nature this is something
this is the craziest day ever democrats
actually get right man this is
something that they like slavery was
legal
it was legal doesn't make it moral
right the fact that there's people we've
talked about this this is the third time
i'm i'm talking
this on your podcast the fact that there
is legal weed
being sold today and there are people in
jail for the rest of their lives for
selling weed is a
moral it's it's something that we all
have to come to grips with this is
immoral this is wrong
this is something that that and i don't
even smoke weed and i'm telling you
the fact that there are corporations
that are making billions of dollars
off of this plant while there's other
people that are going to spend the rest
of their life in prison is wrong
yeah to me this is just outdated uh
outdated
regulations that they have the usada
needs to get together and i bet the
players are going to come up to them and
say hey
what the hell is this all about because
if you look at what happened with ncaa
college athletes are now ready to reap
the rewards of a billion dollar nil
market overdose
over uh open doors is here to help
meaning
uh players are now getting paid in just
a couple years remember how heated the
debates were with college athletes
getting paid
well things are changing this is a
forbes story when blake lawrence
co-founded athlete marketing the
platform open doors in 2012 the iv
college athletes turning the profit on
sponsorships
and endorsements was a pipe dream
outlawed by the double
ncaa but lawrence could see the
opportunity and now with laws allowing
college athletes
to profit from their name images and
likeness nil for the first time
set to take the take effect in seven
states on july 1st his faith is about to
be rewarded
this is going to be a no sleep july
lawrence tells forbes
open doors projects the nil market will
be worth 500 million dollars
in 2022 its first full year before
maturing to roughly a billion annually
every founder dreams of a regulatory
change that creates billion dollar
market in their space overnight
lauren says 32 years old so by the way
props to lawrence in 2012
you come up with this waiting nine years
for this to become a reality from 2012
talk about a visionary by the way
good things uh con they they came out
with this rule or is this a bad thing
them getting paid college athletes bad
thing for the ncaa great thing for
athletes great thing for commerce
uh do ticket prices go up do what what
goes
what how are things effective depending
on the sport
volleyball players aren't making that
loot well that's the thing lacrosse
players it's all gonna be football and
basketball well yeah but
maybe maybe not because you're gonna
look at some
you know like dave portnoys that are
gonna hire these
you know hot model look girls that are
volleyball players okay i mean they
could
easily make a ton of money wearing
certain you know bras and
fitness attire and stuff like that
because they're showing a lot of skin
right so sex sells as well the big thing
is title nine
how does this affect title ix right you
talk about opportunities
is that what that is well it's equal
it's more than equal opportunity it's
equal financing
it's equal payment for you you down here
in miami a-rod i believe it was about 10
years back
a-rod wanted to give two and a half
million dollars to the university of
miami baseball team and they said well
thank you a-rod we have to give
one-and-a-half million to uh the
baseball team and one and a half to the
softball team
i didn't play softball you're like oh
it's title matt and he can't and he's
like okay you don't get the money
so such [ __ ] yeah it's so that that
he should be able to put the money where
he wants to put it right that's the idea
right so so
they they title ix started you know like
everything else and this
literally goes back full circle to the
meet kevin you know
people like to to dismiss it as a
slippery slope policy fallacy it's not
man it is not this is thinking your next
five steps
this is sitting there saying okay what's
happening next there are
actual you know policy decisions that
have negative effects and when you see
the negative effects they have to
attract them but they don't because
there's too much pride
involved especially when it comes to
academia especially when it comes to the
to the far
leftist academia where we know
everything about everything so they get
rid of sports instead of adding to them
cheerleading costs too much money the
most expensive sport
in america is cheerleading the insurance
is through the roof these girls get hurt
all the time they get carried their
freaking neck when they go up to
catastrophic injuries
so they get rid of cheerleading and then
because they get rid of cheerleading
because
it's so expensive well then they have to
get rid of equal amounts
i can see you totally being that dude on
the cheerleading team like just
throwing girls up there in the outer
space basically lifting them up with one
hand i actually can't see you being the
one thrown
[Laughter]
i feel like with gerard and mr olympia
seven times mr let me have phil even
hold on
throw my ass up there that's fine does
it make does it make the athletes better
what this than being able to get paid
because sometimes you know like you need
adversity to actually improve right
where's the motivation for them
look when i played ball in college i
wasn't a star at
all but i could only imagine um
seeing some of these athletes at other
schools driving into mercedes
you know i'm over here driving in the
beat up acura you know
and that person is starting to play
really well
but then next thing you know they're
like what's the motivation for me to go
to class what's the motivation for me to
you know perform like you're now going
to have more opportunity than the coach
so now you're going to be told if you're
a star on the team oh
100 like this what's a trickle-down
effect why are they going to college
anyway guys
like why like like well that's just well
it's going to i don't know how to answer
that
okay i'll give you a perfect example
with football right football
you have to wait until your third year
or your 21st birthday to be draft
eligible right
why why yeah you can tell jason pierre
paul was going to be an nfl player when
he was 17 years old why isn't he going
into a minority
in the nba
you don't think that's a good idea no
not at all so dude if you're
a pro if your son is a prodigy lawrence
taylor in the nfl
but they wouldn't do that you have the
best what's the reason behind it though
what's the reasoning because they have
back room deals with the ncaa
so guess what all of that okay look
here's what i wrote here
a bad idea always gets exposed it's just
period people are eventually going to
expose a bad idea it's a terrible idea
they're going to expose it
here's what i mean by it it's just a
matter of time right to address a couple
things that you got you said
uh here's the first thing uh you said uh
they have to pay the price when you were
going you didn't have any money you were
playing the
basketball for uh colorado university
called university of denver through
university of denver
and you're you're going out there you're
you're majoring in
engineer and you're coming up you're
doing things and then also later on you
become a bodybuilder
you don't have any money like dude i'm
trying to barely eat and i can't get
paid all this other stuff
well here's the thing does this really
change
anything meaning were players really not
getting paid
i mean of course they were getting paid
but they were getting paid illegally now
you're getting paid legally meaning
marijuana is going to be has been sold
for a long time but people sold it
illegally now they're selling it legally
alcohol whether you like it or not
we always had alcohol in our house in
iran it wasn't legal we always had it if
you came to our house my dad had plenty
of alcohol if you wanted
but it was never legal second point here
with
players buying him comes and comes into
the high uh goes from high school to the
nba right he
i don't know if he was a first or not
you had kevin garnett colby all these
guys started coming up
who was the first by the way was kobe
the first
okay so so then check this out so so the
maturity level goes
the 17 18 year old coming in and they
get all this money
into the in the nba right the biggest
concern for me
is a lot of money a lot of success early
and your mindset still doesn't
understand how money works which means
you're going to be abused
you're going to be taking advantage of
them people are going to be taking money
away from you now let's get away from
this part let me go to a completely
different
point here that has to do with
everything we're talking about okay so
san francisco walmart uh not walmart
target and
uh is it walgreens i think it's targeted
cbs okay target and cbs if you want to
go to that story right there
this tells you everything about a bad
idea
okay page seven is the story on target
and
uh walgreens target and walgreens close
early
due to thefts in california stores this
is a fox business story
the target and walgreens are heightening
security efforts in major cities across
california
amid increased theft and crime new
reports suggest los angeles sacramento
los angeles san francisco and sacramento
marxist city is the most
organized retail crime in the country
according to california retail
associations
uh as a result stores have been closing
early or permanently
shuttering operations in the grocery and
retail industries have also
raised concerns about harsher penalties
for theft because right now there is no
debt you can't chase the bad guy
if they come in like literally there's a
girl following following the guy who
stole
stuff he's leaving to say don't touch me
don't touch me just walks out
there's there's videos all over youtube
with people walking and you can't do
nothing about it nothing about it it's a
side business right now people are
paying
three 17 year old kids saying here go
steal as much stuff as you can
we'll pay this much money right so
operators in the grocery and retail
industries
have also raised concerns about harsher
penalties for theft a video surfaced
from earlier this month showing a man
stealing items in san francisco
walgreens and leaving a store on his
bike
with the goods as security guards and
onlookers from the incident walgreens as
a result has also closed several stores
and some security guards
reportedly told not to engage with
shoplifters let me read this again
not to engage with shoplifters so
california thinks
it's a good idea to not chase
shoplifters or it's not a big deal
let them steal the small stuff we're not
going to arrest them didn't we just
cover this with [ __ ]
wait a minute what happens here target
san francisco
change their business hours you know
from what time to what time from nine to
six
they close at six lady says you can't do
this this is
unfair regular just a regular bystander
55 year old ladies like mid 50s
you cannot do this i get off work at six
o'clock i can't even come here and i go
to work at seven o'clock
when do you expect me to come to target
to go shopping during lunch i gotta eat
something
i don't have time to go so the only time
they can go is lunchtime while they're
working
terrible ideas will always be exposed
watch the numbers here theft on rise san
francisco
april 1974 cases by sfpd
okay may 2605
in one month it's an increase of 32
percent going back to what we're talking
about with college athletes not getting
paid
going back to shikari richardson's
getting suspended for one month
you know smoking marijuana bad ideas
will always be exposed
by people it starts off with oh my gosh
by a great salesperson
here's what we should do here's why it's
not this and then boom
the people say nah man listen even
though i'm a democrat or a republican
that's a terrible idea
you gotta arrest these thieves you gotta
arrest these guys because i need
walgreens and
and and target to be open uh listen you
got to pay these college athletes
because i think these guys got to get
paid look this whole three-year thing in
the nfl you can't go in what the hell
are you doing it for because you're
making money on the back end
i'm sorry now that they can get paid now
they're going to say what in five years
let them play at 18 19 years old bad
ideas gerard
historically will always be exposed
always the majority eventually say and
by the way here's the great things about
bad ideas
you know who helps bad ideas get exposed
craziest thing about bad ideas getting
exposed
you know who typically ends up helping
bad ideas being exposed
the people who supported that that bad
idea
not not the people because they'll flip
yourself those are the people
i don't know if i was right now people
who voted for that bad idea saying
yes it's unfair why should we chase
after a shoplifter let's face it it's
only a hundred dollars
and then six months or so that's a
shitty idea yeah i thought it was good
but guess what it's terrible the over
the over there progressive the over
there as long as it's over there it's a
good idea
it comes to my neighborhood oh by the
way it's on both sides listen as a
person that's christian myself
as a person that's a church going guys i
go to sundays i go to church people can
see me at church they're like
you go to church and i'm like yeah i
didn't see you as a person that goes i
said dude i'm probably one of the most
rare random christians you'll find but i
still go to church on sundays because
my life is a big part of what happened
there but go to churches 41
of americans are christians 59 are not
that's your faith you can impose your
faith on everybody else
i'm somebody that understands and agrees
i get it i'm with you but you can't also
judge the other 59
they don't go to the same denomination
they don't live by the same standards
you do
you got to allow them to understand
where they're such so i think it's both
sides of the out there's people on both
sides that typically will eventually
flip and say
you know what i i don't think that like
military i've been a guy that's always
said let's put a bunch of money in
military i'm a military guy
security we need to protect ourselves
you think we're going to fight with m16s
today
you think we're going to need ar you
know you think we're going to fight
if the budget today if it's a hundred
percent amount of us being on weapons
you know how much of the budget i would
flip today to go to cyber security
training to biowarfare training
to you know biowarfare what we just
experienced last 18 months that ruined
the economy for a lot of people made the
rich become extremely wealthy and the
poor got destroyed
thinking policies were good ideas that's
going to help the poor which backfire
theoretically theoretically meaning
meaning what meaning i don't want to get
this video taken down
theoretically theoretically some makes
yeah something i think that finish your
point go ahead no no no no no no no no
no no no go ahead i think ultimately
what you're saying is
the best way to ensure change or to make
changes
a lot of times is to start on the inside
so
for you brought up the example is if a
democrat said look i was supportive of
newsome i was supportive of these
you know not chasing people down but as
a democrat or someone who supported
newsome i just can't go for this anymore
yeah or for what you see on the
republican side of things look i was a
maga guy i supported trump
but after january 6 i got to speak out
the least cheney types
i think the problem is not to cut you
off but i think the problem is that
people are so egotistical that they
will they know they're wrong yeah how
many people really raised their hand and
show accountability that they were wrong
i think phil i think you're absolutely
right i think
the the problem this goes down to i'm on
this team and that's the team i'm
sticking with
and you can't tell me anything otherwise
or they'll just be quiet
but okay i gotta give pushback on this
because
over time it is a both sides issue over
time it is a both sides issue
in this moment it's not in this moment
businesses aren't bending over backwards
sure
they're not bending over backwards to to
fulfill to pander to some right-wing
ideology they're not
they're not moving in some direction
it's not some right wing direction
that's
moving our cities away from from uh
sanity
at this moment listen again when you
want to talk about cheney when you want
to talk about bush when you want to talk
about blood for oil
you want to talk about republicans have
a lot a lot they want to talk about
mitch mcconnell
selling out to china you they have a lot
to account for
but in this moment in particular this
moment
we cannot fix what's happening in this
country unless we identify it
and we can't be afraid that somebody who
can't articulate an argument is going to
call you fat
in the comments because they disagree
with you guys the democrats
have made a very clear decision and
unless we say that's
them unless we say they have sprinted
left
unless we say please i am begging you
i am begging the adults in the room to
take your party back
i am begging the smart moderates to take
their party back
and so that skittles doesn't think
putting a white skittle out there is
somehow changing the world
right it's not a both sides moment we we
can't just
we can't kowtow to people who are
emotionally
devoid of an ability to say you know
what this is wrong but this is this is
literally my point is that
change happens from the inside meaning
as me as some
i'm just using me as an example or even
a meet kevin someone who's voted
democrat or
is known to be a democrat and and i'm
talking to my friends as an example
because a lot of times it happens just
talking like this like how i'm not
standing on a podium speaking at a big
speech
look guys you know this [ __ ] defund
the police thing or this wokeness thing
i don't know how you feel about this i
know you voted for by and i know like
i can't go for this guy i don't know and
then we're talking amongst friends yeah
nobody is listening to the other side of
the party like meaning
there's a bunch of democrats and i'll
just use as an example in german walks
in
you [ __ ] liberal democrats they're
not listening to you
absolutely meaning they'll listen to
someone on their side
flipping flip the switch it has to come
from you know exactly but that doesn't
mean no rest nobody can sit here quietly
until it happens
but just recognize that no one's gonna
change because you think something like
you speak about dealogs if you're a
bunch of mega guys sitting in a room
and some democrats like i don't think
you guys are right they're like get the
[ __ ] out of here
sorry but whatever but if there's a liz
cheney type or if there's someone in the
republican
or even somebody he's a warhawk dude
she's a neocon i'm just giving just an
example buddy i'm giving an example
that if there's someone who's wearing a
freaking mega hat that says look guys
you know i'm maggot out too i just can't
support this insurrection or i can't
support these lies
that's when people will start listening
again okay so ultimately my insurrection
though you're calling it
just give bro you don't got to go you
know like
try to take down each other i'm saying
but change happens this is what i'm
talking about right now
like you guys are talking to me
the person who can't raise their
argument but raises their voice or
raises their emotions loses
i think we have to come down to actually
having that sit down and being like
okay here's the rule because like where
i grew up my parents encouraged debate
and sometimes you know we're being a
black household you know
we yeah but if we can't stay on
topic you lose right away the minute you
start just
going off and drifting into emotions and
the minute you start using name calling
you're out yeah and i think that's where
we need to realize is like
when i watch things on right left
whatever
the minute someone hits them with facts
over feelings oh man they can't handle
that [ __ ] so like we got to get to that
point where we say
look guys like let's stop being soft
here
relax it's just to exchange the goal
is to get to a solution and we can agree
to disagree and i think that's the
biggest thing about being an american
right like you live in a country where
it's okay to disagree with one another
what is not okay is to push
push push push push push push push call
you names flip you off all this other
stuff oh he's a mac a guy you're a trump
supporter or you're this
you're that no i'm not man i'm a human
being with just some opinions man
i just want to be able to have a you
know way of free thought can we have an
exchange
very hard to argue with that point phil
it's a great point by the way here's
what to think about okay you
your point what you said and at your
point uh what you said
gerard that's exactly why i believe
bad ideas get their asses handed to them
eventually by people who voted for the
bad ideas and hear me out here remember
the point i'm trying to make here so for
example
here's what i have a problem with this
is what i have a problem with
is is i've never if you ask mario mario
and i made a list the other day
what does pat like despise like if you
ask what does
what pisses pat off maury made a list
right bad service at a high-end
restaurant
i can't stand it bad service at
applebee's i totally accepted
bad service at mcdonald's that's
acceptable it's totally fine bad service
at chipotle totally fine with it
bad service at ruth chris not gonna
accept it
bad service at maestros that happened
the other day in fort lauderdale not
gonna accept it
bad service at a high-end restaurant i'm
not i'm not gonna accept it it's just
not gonna happen i'm not paying you six
hundred dollars
for three people to get bad service just
not tolerable at all right
you got a few other things people not
showing up on time you got all these
other things that you got right you know
it's one of them that i cannot stand
gerard i can't stand manipulation
i when my parents were getting a divorce
i talked about the same hand full of
time my parents were getting a divorce
i love my mom i love my dad when i would
go to my dad's side he would talk [ __ ]
about my mom when i would go to my mom's
side it would talk [ __ ] about my dad
one time i'm on my dad's family and they
would say he's a borosian
he's an armenian that's what he is he's
a borrowian
and i'm like my my other my mother's
last name is bogorosium
he's a bogosian he's armenia i told my
uncle at that time
i said i swear to god you have to
realize there's three people that matter
in my life my mom
my dad my sister your byproduct if it
wasn't for my dad you wouldn't matter to
me
you only matter to me because you're my
dad's brother that's it if you call out
my mom you'll never see me again
it's a very simple thing and i told my
mom's side the same if you talk trash
about my dad you'll never see me again
that's a simple system because i
couldn't stand
how these two families behind closed
doors destroyed a marriage is what they
did i saw many
i cannot stand manipulation so for
example
we need to defund the police we need to
defund the police we need to defund the
police
the defund the police was always a
republican idea no it wasn't
you came up with it but you realize that
idea backfired on you now you want to
manipulate
that's what i have a problem yeah yeah
instead gaslight exactly
instead i would i would much rather have
last week when i was speaking to god the
assad right
who's absolutely godfather unbelievable
conversation
that's what i have a problem with but
for me look at you yourself
go if there's one of the best inventors
you can take of yourself is the
following
is go back and study yourself and go
moments where certain truths to you were
absolute
that were shaken documented what caused
you being shaken by that
that idea whatever it was it could be
god
it could be parenting it could be
marriage it could be taxes it could be
hard work it could be advancing it could
be
democrats republican independent
president heroes
military whatever it is at one point
like oh my gosh i cannot believe i found
like that my entire life how the hell
did i understand this concept
more of those things need to happen and
we need to openly talk about it
when i was 28 years old i used to think
like this but here's what happened story
about capitalism best story about
capitalism
one of my guys in the company we're in
uh uh i don't know where we are we're
about to go to aruba tomorrow i'm
talking a couple
a couple hundred guys tomorrow to aruba
but we're in somewhere i don't know
we're in dubai or somewhere
and i'm sitting there with one of my
guys who's debating me about the concept
of socialism
okay he said socialism this socialism
that why are you so critical of
socialism
and we're on the beach i'm debating him
his wife and there's like eight people
around
and i said no problem it's all good
buddy you're fine you're right socialism
is a good concept
fast forward six months later he ends up
getting like a ten thousand dollar check
for me some number the number was
i say hey man i got some great news for
you bro yeah
i said dude you got 10 000 on a bonus
check
no way pat are you serious i'm like yeah
dude you freaking crushed it ten
thousand dollars
dude that's so freaking awesome i said
and bro
i have to tell you from having spent the
last eight years with you i've not met
anybody that's as noble and as giving as
you oh thanks pat you know you know how
it is you know it's just
means a lot to us you know what i'm
doing to you here's what i'm doing to
you and i'm gonna make an example of
this because i think everybody needs to
know how big of a noble human being you
are good guy
you know what i'm doing with the 20 with
the ten thousand dollars what i'm giving
your top 20 agents 500 a piece
instead of giving you all the 10 000
because i think that's the way we got to
do it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what are you
talking about
i said dude that's that what are you
talking about bro they did it you didn't
do you didn't build this thing by
yourself
your agency built this spot you didn't
do it so i think instead of giving you
the 10 grand let's get 500 to the top
no that's on he raises his voice and i
let him go i have them on speaking i'm
just saying
i'm salivating yeah right you set him up
he goes
he's got it set him up and then you know
what i said at the end i said you know
what
you are right you earned the ten
thousand dollars
you believe in capitalism that socialism
i do as well
silence he says bad i get your point
here's your 10 grand bro maybe the next
time you think you're a socialist
don't forget how you act like a
capitalist because you busted he asked
for this bonus
you know i never thought about it that
way before the conversation on social i
mean
he still votes left but the concept of
socialism is a noble concept
is out of his mind that's happened to me
my family many many times these are the
moments where we realize
bad ideas eventually time is bad ideas
worst enemy
how did you see him change after that
incident he he looked at capitalism in a
completely different way
he sent me a book one time called the
capitalism and slavery
uh and we were going back i mean by the
way one of my best friends in the world
today this is a guy that i love talking
to
you know his sons are like my nephews
they text me we talk to each other they
just graduated from
big universities i think it's howard
whatever the big universities in
atlanta are the big ones they went to
these are ridiculous parents morehead
hard-working parents exactly grew up in
compton this guy
he grows up in compton comes out of
compton as a single mother is the only
thing he has in drugs gangs
ends up becoming a doctor he becomes a
doctor youngest principal in san
bernardino valley are you talking
against the doctor
right no i'm not
the point i'm talking to you about is
live a long time
just keep living believe me many of your
bad ideas are going to be exposed i've
experienced this personally
okay i don't disagree with you that
they're going to get exposed
i am losing faith or i have lost faith
in the willingness of the public to
force
our bureaucracy to change the bad ideas
i just lived through
18 months of getting non-stop gas lit
about trust the science trust the
scientists and as the science became
more and more and more clear that this
was trust the propaganda trust the
propaganda
people doubled down confirmation bias
confirmation and
it was also let's just call it what it
was it was an addiction
to control they became addicted to the
power they became addicted to the
control
and it's it's a learning moment and it's
a teaching moment
because this is so effective this is not
the last time this is going to happen
this is not the last time this is going
to happen have they realized that they
could actually go from one side to the
other side i think that's what we're
talking about with the
whole you know socialist and capitalist
story is that it's okay
to change you mean absolutely yeah of
course you know i think it's important
you know that people recognize just the
data the facts and just stick with that
and say you know what i used to think
this way now i don't
and i'm good no matter what i'm still
good about this
i might change a year from now back but
i have that right
it's almost like we have to empower
people to actually
know that they have the permission to
choose principles used to be
something that people were like if you
were a man of principle
and the times changed that was actually
a virtue you know what i'm saying it's
like your favorite uh
wrestler becoming the heel yeah right
sometimes
you didn't like him but then you realize
like i don't have to
i don't have to and then he comes back
and you're like yay
okay cool it's like lebron goes from
cleveland to miami people are like man i
used to love this guy and then he comes
back oh i love him again
you have the right to choose and it's
okay here's here's my thoughts on what
you're saying gerard
did you want to finish yeah well well
the thing is i think what bothers me is
exactly what he's saying
it's that principle right because there
was a time
when the democrat was the person that
was going after the the judgmental
christian right
and was free speech absolutist was the
person that was no blood for oil
that said you know the the profiteering
off of a tragedy of 9 11 to then get us
into a
a trillion dollar boondoggle in the
middle east they were they were the tip
of the spear
on what was good moral and just and now
they are
today's democrat is the christian
conservative of my youth
they cancel people they're judgmental
they use their their pseudo religion
as as a reason to exclude people right
there's a very clear in
and out you know there there's very
clear being
of the membership has its perks you know
if you wanna if you wanna get on tv you
gotta be one of us you know membership
has its perks there's no principle well
this goes back to pat saying the bad
ideas will get exposed
what changes see if we all we know that
this
is wrong we're talking about it that
it's wrong they know that it's wrong
and still three trillion dollars just
got changed
but you have to realize first of all
there there's
there's a few things where you're right
the
breaking point hasn't hit yet for people
to finally say and sometimes i know this
is going to sound strange
sometimes you need as a human being a
massive setback
you just do sometimes look the way the
way this this
god creator whatever you want to call it
is created the system
take a look at the system so you're born
you're growing up you admire your
parents then you're like dude stop
telling me what to do man leave me alone
and you're 16 17 years old you're
embarrassed about being around your
parents because it's really bothering
you and you're like don't tell me
anything to do
and then you grow up you get married
then you have kids then when you have
kids you're like dude dad can you guys
come around because i want you to be
around the kids i need your help
now go now you need me yes and then they
come around your kids and then your kids
are like daddy i love you but they you
know
you know you know what you're talking
and the kids going to become closer to
grandparents
and then all of a sudden somebody dies
and you say man i miss
you know and then boom you continue like
okay man you go no
you get fired you lose a job you go
through an earthquake you go through a
war you go through this you go through
losing everything's like
perspective perspective perspective
perspective perspective then you get
humbled humbled humble humble humbled
and then you pass that wisdom down
hopefully the right people listen
this is a cycle that's been going on for
a very very long time this system
every once in a while we don't just need
a shakeup we need an
ass whooping you ever heard somebody
that's so arrogant where you say dude
that guy just needs to get knocked out
already
like now you know what who said this on
twitter the other day oh mike tyson mike
tyson said this to you mike tyson
you know some of you guys on twitter you
know if you talk to me like you talk me
to my face like that you know what i
would do to you
some of you on twitter need to get
slapped you know knocked up
you know so and that we need that as a
nation sometimes
you need that as a community sometimes
but i'm telling you right now
i don't think people are now rising up
but i do think the challenge is when you
do have an argument that you want to
make as a following
here's the challenge here's the
challenge went to acting school
years ago in an acting school i'm
sitting with this guy and he says i want
you to say i love you 50 different times
you've probably done this before when
you go to acting school and he says okay
i'm gonna say what i want you say i love
you 50 different times i'm like
shoot how do you say it here we go i
love you i'm having a hard time looking
at you saying i love you i'm looking at
you right now
i love you i love you i love you a lot
me too so you go through i love you i
love you i love you
i love you i love you that's what you
really was talking about so you going
back and forth and then eventually like
man i can really say them 50 different
times
well if you tell somebody you're a piece
of [ __ ] take your piece
you know it's so the method of
communication
to convert needs to improve because
not necessarily tone i don't mind
enthusiasm and fire
and you know you look at some of the
greatest influencers they had a lot of
passion i don't mind
obama getting up on stage and talking
about i don't care if you're green black
red brown gay straight military
we need to come like i don't mind that
like when i see an orator on stage going
up right
but if you talk to me like i'm an idiot
i'm not converting right i'm shutting
down yeah
i think the delivery this is why any
generation that's ever had somebody that
had the biggest converter
they had a certain method of converting
people that is the key
fundamental key of converting folks and
i bent
i bet on every generation having a
handful of heroes that rise up that
fight
and eventually the best idea wins it's
just what's happened historically
america right now is a democracy okay we
can debate and have discourse and go
back and you can say whatever you want
to say with raising taxes you think
anybody the whole 94 raising taxes did
it really work permanently
no look what happened to the raising of
taxes do you think this
raising the debt costs the way they're
doing is a permanent thing you think
that's going to work permanently
you don't think we're going to pay price
for this that's the anxiety that people
have they'll pack because i mean this is
our one life
it's going to happen they're playing
nobody is going to happen to them but
bro
you're saying this is our life right
this is our life okay this is our life
go back to 80 years prior to you and i
go to 20s
that's their life how shitty was the 20s
how shitty was the 40s mm-hmm go to the
30s were the worst
but going to the 1860s the 40s were
pretty bad
yeah but but what i'm saying go to the
1860s go to the 1700s
go to the 1600s yeah what i'm trying to
do
your words two weeks ago freaking we're
living in the greatest times of the time
we just are the most spoiled brats we've
ever been in the history of mankind and
this message we give our kids like
you know do you realize what your daddy
used to do it's like oh my gosh you
lived such a rough life and in the back
of my mom i'm like only if you know what
kind of a life my dad lived like that
yeah
only if you know how to leverage my
grandpa and then you go back and forth
maybe we're the ones that's a little bit
too pansy
and we don't show gratitude enough and i
think that's the biggest issue
and a lot of parents are soft you know
and they just don't know how to
communicate
you know like they don't have to talk
about their own stuff they for instance
you know i went to the
university of denver tons of rich kids
tons
one of my good friends he played hockey
there his dad owns like one of the
largest dealerships in all of canada
you know what he used to tell me he goes
you know what phil what's great is that
i know i'm rich i know i am
but i work my butt off like i don't have
anything
and he really does a lot of kids say
that [ __ ] but they don't
but i think it's important that he says
like i don't have a rough life okay i
had a great head start
but my grandfather holy smokes did that
guy have it rough and he was able to
teach a lot of things to my father who
taught me and and i think that's where
we need to be because i mean
i don't have kids but if i were i'm not
going to sit here and tell them like
they you know like i had the roughest
life i'll say that my mom did my dad did
those are those things and those are the
lessons that i learned from them and i'm
teaching you like hey
be in gratitude for what you have so
that you don't repeat mistakes that we
have made
so there's a guy uh pat i know you're a
fan of him his name is brett weinstein
he has a podcast called the dark house
podcast uh and great great great uh
we've talked about it last night great
podcast
with his wife heather um you know it's a
little long and it's very academic
it's but it's they they talk about some
really high level concepts it's really
cool
and he's an evolutionary biologist so
the reasoning behind this is essentially
what he considers evolutionary lag we
have gotten
so complex and so connected so fast that
like our neurological system hasn't been
able to catch up we still look at the tv
and our mind sees it as a window to the
outside world like we're literally
looking outside the window
so if all we're ever watching and if all
we're ever seeing is the barbarians at
the gates
well then we're constantly going to have
the anxiety now the other side of it is
when something's good outside you just
take a look and you're like all right
everything's good then you go about your
business
but when you start seeing the dark
clouds come out and you start saying oh
man i got to prep for this i got to do
this how do i move
that's how we capture attention so we're
con we're in evolutionary lag
and and this is something maybe and this
is kind of to your point about
the patience and then you're you're a
little bit older to me so you can have a
little bit more of that perspective for
sure
but it's the give it time everything's
going to be okay
i'm kind of in this idea of looking at
this now like we better nip this in the
bud
we better nip this in the bud man we
better nip this totalitarian crap in the
bud
otherwise so my anxiety is about keep it
no you keep it like that no but listen
you're talking about one of the most
yeah i'm a pretty paranoid guy when it
comes down to a lot of things like every
time like just see where i sit when we
go to restaurants my behavior
certain things don't i'm fully on the
same page there
i plan on doing my part the next 20 to
40 years i had an interesting call with
a guy yesterday
who's asking me about what's going on
with iran and the new guy that's the
leader of iran you know who's an
absolute murderer killer what do you
think about what's going on with iran
and all these different 25-year deals
with china i said listen
i'm gonna do my part but it's gonna take
20 to 40 years
because i'm going to take my kids to
iran i'm going to show them ho chat
where i want to show them jam hospital
i'm going to show guru bank young school
where i want to i'm going to show them
esperhon
which is the only trip i want to on a
trip with my family
i'm going to show them cinema rex where
the fire i'm going to show my kids that
it's going to happen before this guy
dies god willing right
that's a 20 to a 40-year plan you we
ain't going to be able to do anything to
iran for the next five years
it's 20 to 40 years to turkey syria
yeah and we're gonna do our part but at
the same time
delivery perspective knowing the fact
that people like you are always gonna be
around
fighters in every generation you cannot
change
churchill you cannot change a person
that's a dog
fight crazy insane willing to stand up
against anybody
you cannot change people like that they
don't know any other way
you can't tell them to say dude just
kick back that does they're not wired
that way
all i'm saying is delivery messaging
converting
coming from a place where we convert if
we're only talking to our base to go
find our base then you're a marketer
you're not a true believer
i don't know if that made sense or not
because i can go out there and say
certain
you know how many preaching to the
conversion do you realize how many
people message me and they say
i can't i stopped following your podcast
the moment you said what you said about
trump and all this i'm like
okay great you know how many people tell
me i can't stand your podcast because
you're a trump supporter i'm like dude
you guys are all confused by the way
so if i wanted to only get a base i
could have gone in that direction
the direction we're going is dude let's
let's talk openly let's have a discourse
let's realize what we got going on let's
bring people from different
you want to debate you want let's go but
afterwards what people don't see is you
guys are having cigars to get a kicking
back having a good time i don't know
yeah you guys go into a a uh what do you
call it uh uh
uh uh karaoke this guy crushes it in
karaoke by the way
adam uh what adam's saying what i want
to know what love is
what's that i want you you're saying
what happened no no no no no adam sango
what was that one song i'm all out of
love there it is i'm so lost without you
i don't know
dude yeah i love the soy man the so me
and the soy man have great conversations
by the way he's a message and he's a
man's man dude what i preach about you
is that
you genuinely do like america you
genuinely do love america you you
you are the democrat i grew up with if
every time a jfk bill clinton democrat
yeah if everybody was like that man i'd
be a-okay with it i
don't know i'd not be able to agree with
you but this is the thing
that's that aoc is part of the the
justice democrat problem and it's it's
this is again maybe it's because i i've
i've been behind the curtain
so i see behind it right so again how
the sausage is i've seen how the sausage
is made
he wouldn't let me even eat a hot dog
this weekend he's like i've seen all
these hot dogs
i don't eat that [ __ ] yeah do mine out
so they're gonna primary
moderates joe manchin's gonna get
primaried i bet you and now joe manchin
again i've said it to you and i'll say
it again
joe manchin has held this union together
without joe manchin
the united states of america in 2021
does not exist who called domestic
leave that in my life two months ago i
believe that in my soul
i really honestly i've been talking
about him for yeah but both sides are
going to get
married you've seen trump basically i
don't think so trash
i don't think they're gonna get
primaried on the right because it's
already happening the smartest thing
that wright's done in 20 years is shut
up
they they've shut up they have if you
see what they're doing now they are just
being quiet
and letting the infighting happen over
there and and that tells you how bad
their ideas have been for so long
that they're getting the most traction
they've gotten in a generation by saying
nothing
that's at that start when did they start
saying nothing about 12 months ago
yeah i've heard them be pretty vocal for
the last two by the way here's a guy
bishman just gave 10 bucks and he said
pbd you are right about delivery i voted
for obama
bernie in 16 20 for biden but i agree
with points and philosophy i can admit
you pushed me to the center of cup on
couple of issues that's what this
podcast's all about we like
they like it publicly though he just did
he gave 10 bucks for it and he admitted
republican
hiding behind the twitter what goes back
to whatever at the end of the day it
comes down to not
being black or white it's there's gray
areas you got to be fluid your things
are changing
phil gave a poignant um response that's
a good segue in the
azalea by the way okay phil gave a point
of response about
being open to hearing what's out there
and evolving i mean you were talking
about that i think it's important
because
if you have a willingness to learn new
things that's what you have to do
you know in my world it would be like uh
you know different training disciplines
or even different diets
but if you sit in the center and you
just hear both sides you should want to
hear both sides and then you can make an
educated decision for you
and be okay like but guys i mean we got
to be honest though there's a reason why
we don't air both sides because when
people on the left
say anything about the left they get
killed they get killed in the media
and i'm sorry they get cancelled they
get when people on the left say about
what anybody that's that's on the the
lead level
if they ever say that they get killed so
my thing is guys i know you i i'm
sounding like you know johnny right wing
over here
i'm just trying to be hon like we can't
be honest about what's going on in the
country we have to call it what it is
we we have to say there's no question
about that there's no question about
that
johnny right now no no no no no no no no
no no no no every time i johnny cash
right away let's transition into this
here's another terrible idea that i hope
people
will figure out why this is a terrible
idea 130 nations agreed to support u.s
proposal for global
minimum tax on corporations okay if you
want to go to page eight
uh here we go treasury secretary janet
yellen announced thursday that a group
of 130 nations has agreed to global
minimum tax on corporations part of a
broader agreement to overhaul
international tax rules yellen did not
announce the actual rate at which the
gmt would be international attack
would be set but the biden
administration has pushed push for at
least 15 percent if widely enacted
the gmt would effectively end the
practice of global corporations
seeking out low tax jurisdictions like
ireland and british virgin island to
move their headquarters to
even though their customers operations
and executives are located elsewhere the
gmt agreement representative a key part
of the
what biden uh president joe biden has
called the foreign policy for middle
class right
130 nations out of the 130 nations
france is one of them china china's
another one india is another one okay so
you got
you got superpowers it's not like you
don't have anybody why is this a
terrible idea can i give you my thoughts
yeah i'm going to come to you next time
i actually wanted to tee you up and see
if i'm right go for it as for you
because i know you have very strong
feelings this tell me
the one thing i wrote about this was
this is anti-capitalism
and limiting competition is is that
where you're going is that
so here's here's uh uh here's why i
don't like this idea
okay here's why i don't like to save you
i've lived in uh
many different places i lived around 10
years two years germany california 24
year 22 years
tennessee kentucky dallas five years now
florida five months going on to six
months right
okay so for me if you live in a city
you live in an apartment complex or a
community you're living you don't like
what can you do
go vote change your zip code you go to a
different zip code okay
if you don't like the city you're living
in what can you do
go to another city vote with your feet
if you don't like the region you're
living in what can you do go to
if you don't like the states you live in
to where can you go to another state
if you don't like a certain east coast
west coast whether you don't you can go
to a different places but it's different
in a country but if you
have a problem with a country you can go
to a different country if they do this
you can't because there is no more
competition
what this does the only time you come up
with something like
this is when you're worried about
somebody passing you up
the only time you come up with something
like this is when you're worried about
somebody passing you up now
china says i'm in do you actually think
china is going to follow the rules no no
what do you mean china's end oh yeah
we're in as if we're going to live
we're 100 in right no i have a problem
because
the the healthy aspect of holding people
accountable
is absolute competition gerard said
something very interesting the other day
when he came down to sports he says i
think every sport needs competition
nba doesn't have competition mlb doesn't
have competition nhl doesn't have
competition nfl doesn't have competition
i said but aren't they each other's
competition he said yes
but also no right because in ufc if i
want to go ufc they keep picking up
everybody pride whatever is out there
how the hell can i go out there and
compete you got jake paul trying to
defend a
fighter that's saying hey don't worry
about it i'm going to take care of you
here you know coming on
who just got just won the uh heavyweight
title that's pretty
two weeks later that's pretty massive to
see some of these situations that are
taking place so the fighters are sitting
there saying
i'm not getting paid the kind of money i
need to get paid now they're getting
exposed
and we were talking about poor year
against the uh conor mcgregor yeah and i
made my recommendation this is a part
three of fighting i think i think if
there's ever been
a time where a guy like if all the mobs
hypothetically purely hypothetical if if
the mobsters
exist i mean there's no such a thing but
let's just say if there was such a thing
as a mop we know it doesn't exist it's
just
in movies correct but if there's such a
thing as the mob
if there's ever been a time to call
somebody to take a dive
for a couple million dollars probably a
good time to do it right now
if somebody's gonna call and i'm not
saying it's gonna i'm not even putting
the idea out there
all i'm saying is you just did if dustin
gets a call and says hey
five million bucks just take a dive okay
why who do you think dana wants to see
the fight the 100 million dollar member
mcgregor nobody wants to see podium or
gsp or any of that
but can you imagine a khabib reunion
against
connor who comes back can you imagine
conor against gs can you
imagine if that takes place right and
the part we went to
when we were talking about uh um how
dana's uh doing what he's doing where
you can't take fights or any
sponsorships that you do they have to
have to be only what you were talking
about they have to go through the ufc it
has to be the ufc sponsor they can't get
external money you can't get ext
external sponsorship it has to be only
to one can capitalize on your image and
you know you know you know what i was
going to say yesterday when i said i'm
going to say today on the podcast here's
what it is
you know who dana doesn't want as an
enemy same person jeff bezos didn't want
as an enemy
jeff pesos is more glad uh more open to
the idea of paying more taxes
there's one thing bezos doesn't want
regulation union
oh not want union
ufc will get destroyed oh my god union
enters it by the way
if union enters it dana cannot be dana
they have to go get somebody like an
adam silver if
union enters ufc dana's fired
because dana's they shut it down i don't
think i don't think they'd even go
through with it
no they wouldn't shut it down are you
kidding me any opportunity for the union
people to make money memberships taxes
oh hell no these are the most
capitalistic
controls i'm talking about i think zuffa
and dana white i think they
i think they they lock down the ufc they
can't do that though
they can't do that when you sell a
company for that price and you get three
and a half billion dollars and you got
350 you can't play those cards you just
cannot do it you're gonna you have so
many
they will put him in court for the rest
of his life to ruin his life he's not
gonna do that he's got a great life
but if you go at bet with union that's
not a
that's that's one part that he has to
realize if there's anything that he has
to just yesterday so going back to this
yeah i'm a fan of competition and this
eliminates competition so what do you do
if i can move to another city if i can
move to another state
if i can move to a different region if i
can move to a different coast
but if i can't move to another country
because everything's the same where do i
go do i go to another planet
yeah hey elon kind of hurry up because i
may want to come to the cultural planet
right yeah you know what i mean
just from devil's advocate i know we
like giving different perspectives
give me the flip side why this would be
a good idea so they're going to bring in
tax money good idea the good idea is the
fact that they don't want the offshore
accounts they don't want these smaller
countries that are kind of getting the
business out of the islands of the world
yeah they don't want
that but but you know what take that the
offshore account money
dude how much money is it you know one
of the most hated presidents of all time
came up with one of the best ideas of
all time the guy's name is what what's
his name
i think it's trump donald trump right
yeah so he
just said hey for a period of time
if you bring your money from offshore to
here
you pay five percent taxes or ten
percent ten percent i believe hey
you bring your 22 billion paid 2.2
billion how many how many companies did
it though
well do you know why they burger king
asked the question why they didn't do it
so pat why did they do it because they
knew eventually when the administration
changes they're going to go back to the
same rules and they're going to find a
way to go back and get that money
retracted
this is globalism guys this is build
back better this is the great reset this
is what they've been telling us straight
in our face you're going to own nothing
and you'll be happy you know they just
took they just did what was it
three and a half trillion dollars wealth
transfer as soon as they came in three
and a half trillion
dollars it's not enough now we gotta go
get global money
now we gotta go go go make sure that we
can tax
everybody everywhere in the globe if
you're working
in the world your money's our money
we own you baby money is the hours of
our lives do you think that people
aren't up in arms about this because
lives 15 doesn't seem like a crazy
number
no it was 40 people freaking out right
up in arms bro what up in arms
like honestly let me ask you a question
who gives a [ __ ] about this
major business people who are understand
about offshore accounts the average
person doesn't give a [ __ ] about no no
who you
guarantee people in ireland corporations
yeah who guarantee
what actually percentage-wise what
percentage of america
cares about corporate taxes one-half of
one-half that's the point yeah i agree
so people are like that doesn't affect
me they don't realize it affects
them what are you talking about it
doesn't affect you of course it affects
you
the fact that listen if every morning i
wake up
worried about somebody taking away my
market share yesterday
it's fourth of july yesterday's fourth
of july yesterday's fifth july right
yeah i took one day off for a fifth of
july the next day i'm at the office
fourth of july
we were at the house we're doing what
we're doing yesterday i'm at the office
all day here
and i'm doing what i'm doing and one of
the guys like dude why are you at the
outset i don't have a choice buddy
i'm running multiple i chose this life
that's right i chose to run a business
if i don't my competition is and i have
to play offense
i want our politicians to say i have the
same kind of competition we have where
they go to sleep worried about losing
business
it's very good for taxpayers if our
politicians worry every single
night about business owners going to a
different state different city different
country
that only benefits taxpayers only
benefits taxpayers
if they don't have that kind of
competition to go to sleep with they
have a monopoly why should you have a
monopoly
then regular people when they have a
monopoly they go to jail or they get
broken apart but you don't have a
monopoly who are you to play by your own
set of rules
nah that's not how this thing works
right if if you want to have a set
if you want to have a monopoly law if
you want to put it on us
put it back on yourself right i mean
look so if they if they're going to do
this stuff they have to at some point
and
this is us as the people we have to
force them they got to show their work
you got to prove something at some point
like
we're talking uh with me kevin he said
dianne feinstein and
nancy pelosi both have like nine figure
networks now
nine figure networks meanwhile san
francisco is gonna have they're saying
of the people in their district of san
francisco are looking to leave by 2022
they're looking at losing population in
their district
and they've they've become billionaires
by ruining
their districts like like at some point
we have to say all right dude
how much money does it take to run this
country if we can't run the thing on 3
billion you're telling me we give you
another
three billion six billion is gonna do it
by the way six billion what's it gonna
take
you know what's crazy what you just said
the story that you guys didn't want to
cover which is elam last takes aim at
ula says parent company
lockheed darkened the skies and lobby so
you know the whole story about that do
you know the whole story behind why
there's a controversy there between
these two guys going
yeah military industries let me read it
to you and you'll see kind of what the
difference is because that's exactly
what you just said here so
uh elon musk takes aim at ula's his
parent company lockheed dark in the
skies and lobbyists this is a fox
business story spacex founder and ceo
elon musk has continued his criticism
of the united launch association for
accepting government money musk's
criticism came in on a wednesday tweet
when he responded to a comment from ula
president and ceo ceo
tony bruno who suggested that uli's
vulcan
centaur rocket could compete with
spacex's reusable rockets ula would be
dead
as a door nail without the tool launch
provided dod requirement musk tweeted
referencing on air force contract called
the eelv
launch capability payment worth hundreds
of millions of dollars per year must
continue
if this is not true then you won't have
a problem removing it your parent
company lockheed darkened the skies with
lobbyists to ensure f35
was single source in 2014 a spacex sued
the air force
over its contract given solely to ula
hence
monopoly the two entities reached a
settlement in 2015. you know who helped
help this settlement be be done john
mccain
musk's call out is the following he's
saying it costs you
twice as much of taxpayers money to go
to space than it costs me
why are you spending taxpayers money the
way you are so he's calling out
one is a private company which is with
spacex the other one is a public
company which is what ula this is crony
capitalism
corruption this is this is not only this
is a perfect example
of what happens if there is no
competition
yeah this is the perfect example of what
happens if they don't have competition
and elon musk is calling it out
yeah which is needed of course it's
needed in every possible way it's needed
i mean look you know it's interesting
you see it as crony capitalism i see
this as the
this is the essential downfall of
socialism and centralization
this is where the government picks its
winners and looters
and there's no competition and there's
no market force involved when there's no
market force to say
like we talked about this a couple weeks
ago where it was like elon musk was the
first person
he's definitely not the first person in
nasa that was like you know what we
should bring the rockets back and reuse
them like we got these flying buildings
maybe you don't drop them in the ocean
these things cost a lot of money but it
was just taxpayer money they were like
nah who needs it let's build another
pen yeah dude like it's gone so he
when you're in the market you know when
you're when you have shareholders to
answer to
accountability accountability
accountability it's a good
thing right now i'm not saying that
government doesn't necessarily
have a place in investing in places
because capitalism has really struggled
in two places specifically
they struggle in uh research development
and they struggle in art
all right so artists all of our artists
end up being you know
hyper socialists and and and uh
communists because
when they're coming up in their
developmental stages there is no
market for them and their stuff does
take a lot of time it takes a lot of
time to become
good at being an actor a bodybuilder
right how much
time does it take to get your body how
much effort does it take to get your
place
your your physical being in a place
where you're like yeah i could be
professionally good looking like that
takes a long time right
but there's no money along that stretch
right there's nothing there's no
incentive you've got a 10-year plan
where there's no way you're going to
generate revenue out of what you're
spending all your time effort and energy
on listen gerard you just
wait till you see what i have in mind
for bodybuilders
okay let me put it to you this way if if
if
what i have in mind takes place over the
next couple years two to five ten years
we're going to create a business model
for bodybuilders to make the kind of a
money they've never made before
they've never made before but in order
for that to happen we got to kind of be
able to have our own contest like let's
just say we were
if we were to run mr olympia you just
kind of threw this out there and kind of
my
mind automatically went there if we were
running mr olympia
what i would do to the mr olympia brand
and i know this sounds a little bit
too confident to say what i would do the
plans
we would put in place for mr olympia
bodybuilders
would be sitting there saying finally
somebody flipping did it
that you gave us a platform to make
money to be appreciated
to be in movies to have our message be
out there to be able to get sponsorships
to be able to live in
a place where we're making economic to
to be able to have our identity
change instead of just seeing a bunch of
muscle heads somebody's showing how
brilliant and intelligent we are to be
able to realize how technical this is
you're almost like a scientist to become
a bodybuilder it would change the game
because i think bodybuilding
is is a business model that can really
everybody in the world
looks and admires a nice six-pack
everybody in the world likes one of
these when a guy flexes his dylan sees a
muscle
i said dylan touch phil's biceps he
touches phil's biceps dylan's like
oh my gosh it's so thick
dylan says it's like i want muscles like
that right
watch what we're gonna do to the
bodybuilding world in the next couple
years hey
bodybuilders if you're listening up just
think about it if you're
if you had a full support management
you know somebody that's getting you out
there getting you exposure
helping you make money creating content
for you giving you millions on top of
millions of views
uh having you to get new opportunities i
don't know i want to stop right there
it's just if that ever came across
in your opinion what is broken in the
bodybuilding world that
pat even like a a businessman a
capitalist
who has never you know professionally
competed says i can come in and do
something better
which is sort of the story of capitalism
what is it that's broken right now what
needs to be fixed
direct connection meaning like um
what am i gonna get for what you're just
saying
these men and women i mean they put a
lot of time
a lot of effort and if we were to really
write it down how much money and time
that they put into their physique
they'd be so in the red the black that
you know people would say well how are
we gonna sell this
you must really love this [ __ ] because
you're not making money from this
the biggest thing i think is the lack of
opportunity for
athletes to sit at the table and i think
a lot of times
um you know the athletes like myself for
instance
when the magazines were going on i think
there was a lot more opportunity because
you know you're getting eyeballs on you
through the magazines when the digital
age came
there was really there was really no sit
down with all the
top athletes and saying like this is a
platform that we're gonna make for you
to make money
because a lot of you people didn't go to
college you didn't have you know these
conversations
we were just focusing on you know
training and dieting because that's
freaking hard
but right now i don't know i nailed diet
and personally i think we're at a great
point in time where we can have this
conversation but i think
in order for i think we you know just
need
more dialogue of saying like look
you're only making like like look like
for instance i went to a show
last weekend i think one of the girls
she placed like third in a
figure competition you only made like
500 bucks 500
how much did she have to invest to even
get to that point easily 20 grand in the
year
easily easily so like what is her
motivation
what is her motivation when she comes
home she made more than that are only
fans dude
right that's a problem and that's a
problem so i mean i i think it's really
important that we we look at this and
say look like
i need to invest money in these people
so then they can actually do better
these are these are people that have
amazing stories these are people that
have
amazing triumphant stories and they and
they actually personal train people they
they train people through ebooks and all
those other they're very influential
but it's really hard to keep them
motivated and keep them locked in
for the long period of time when they're
not getting paid
i mean one of the girls that did the
miss olympia physique competition shanee
grant
very young you know bright star she won
the olympia a couple of times
if she was getting paid more money she
wouldn't have retired
now i understand she wanted to have a
family and stuff like that god bless her
you know good luck with that
but i guarantee you if she had a couple
zeros
extra she might say you know what
i'll have this kid but i'm coming right
back you know what you know what
confuses me the most here's the
following thing that confuses me the
most okay here's what's confusing the
most
you know a lot of people take shots at
uh ufc you know it's like ufc this ufc
that dana white does dana white that
uh would you say dana white takes care
of his number one guys like does
god do his number ones make money yeah
yes
he's the number one he's not making
money how the hell is he not making
money
and i'm talking like he should make five
ten million a year to be able to get the
other guys to say i want to be him yeah
how the hell does that even happen yeah
you got 16 different people in the
history of mr olympia that have won mr
olympia 16.
the last three years has been a person
that's wanted 1-1-1
anytime mr olympia is winning one at a
time there is no legacy there is no
excitement
do you want to see like a stretch like
oh my gosh i want to go see ya's i want
to go see heath i want to see
ronnie i want to see arnold i want to
see haney i want to see i want to see
the
i want to see cutler 4x like damn look
at cutler right one
two one two it's like dude look at this
stuff right when he's coming right i
want to see that
how does how do number ones why is it so
many guys that are number ones from mr
olympia how come how come
how come there are money i don't get
that so so the whole thing
where they say dana treats his athletes
like he owns them
mr olympia treat their athletes like
they own them and it's purely now this
is me my
this is not his position this is my
position he disagrees with me and he'll
say he'll defend the brand because the
brand has changed his life in many ways
this is me saying this
he this is not his position anybody from
astrology that's watching this pbd is
saying this he's not saying this
but i see it and i talk to a lot of the
guys who are bodybuilders who are
winners and i say how do i treat you
i've never heard anybody say they treat
me royally how the hell is that possible
everybody's like walking on eggshells
paid the damn number one guy
what are you doing how many interviews
have you done with the top bodybuilders
we have the most
innermost views on bodybuilding ever on
all of it and i've only done like 10 of
them
i stopped doing them eventually i'm like
i'm done with this but i tell you
if the right owner ownership ran mr
olympia look what would happen to those
bodybuilders they need a dana white type
is what you're saying they need teddy
moscow brothers
you have to go out and address all the
criticism i wouldn't be running it in
the
the way i would run the model is a very
different way than i run my insurance
company it's a very different way
it would be a i don't even want to see i
don't want to give the ideas
i'll tell you i'll tell you one major
thing i'm not going to do it until you
want to heat it up
yeah let's go athlete just needs to be
asked one question what do you want
that's it
no i think i think if i feel like that's
like the notebook right there what do
you want
i think yeah if someone said what do you
want phil
and just sat back and listened yeah
didn't and then you know
a lot of athletes are conditioned to not
even like know what to ask
because they haven't been asked those
questions i think at the end of the day
you want like for instance um
you know i never won an arnold classic
columbus ohio trophy right yeah i did
the arnold classic in europe
so one of the promoters was like phil
you gotta do this show you gotta do this
show for me
for you okay you're gonna pay me to show
up
he was like what i said you know when
tiger woods goes to the pga phil heath
yeah
when tiger woods goes to one of these
invitationals because this is an
invitational
you you pay for his flight his hotel has
everything
you give him a signing fee what are you
going to do for me
and you know what he says there won't be
any money is it all about the money phil
i said that's funny because you flew
here on private
and i'm flying here on business you flew
here on private to australia
are you nuts so the lack of recruitment
is what i'm saying like i cannot stand
that [ __ ]
you should say whatever you want because
at the end of the day
if i say i want one of those cards right
there i want that mercedes
and you say here try drive mine for the
day
and i'll get you one next week you don't
think that i'm gonna train my ass off
even more and more
and more and more and more so i think
you know if they don't offer anything if
they don't dangle a carrot
yeah in addition to the trophy um you're
not going to get the athletes to stay
motivated and
you're not going to and when i say this
i i say this with all sincerity
you're going to have bodybuilders that
are going to focus more on being
influencers
than competitors we don't need that and
we don't need more influencers
we want the less influence i want to see
the best on stage be focused just on the
show
because that's what i did so what's the
carrot right now just a trophy
yeah cover of a magazine maybe there
won't there's no covers of magazines
so therefore i mean the average
bodybuilder is having to rely on
sponsorship
because the shows don't pay enough now i
i definitely feel like um the shows
could
you know i just feel like you know for
the olympia
you know i think there's a lot of
conversation that needs to happen i
think for the arnold classic there needs
to be a lot of conversation and at the
end of the day all they have to do is
just sit us down
you know if someone wanted me to do one
of the shows right
have they called when i said last time i
said my phone's on
you think anyone called they didn't
because sometimes
they don't want power to the player but
i think what happened with ufc
when conor mcgregor raised all hell
called dana white out and also stuff and
said you know i'll go back to england
i'll be nobody again you don't think
they had a conversation
they not only had a conversation they
probably asked them what he wanted and
if he didn't know he's like well i have
an idea for you we'll get you your own
liquor or this and that and the other
next thing you know you're doing that
you're doing this you're doing that now
he's walking around with that strut
you know doing his thing actually what
happened with habib as well when habib
wanted to retire dana white said well
hold on
like let's have a conversation whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
david david right there there he goes
nice drop it david yeah
pleasure but i think you were talking
trash about the purdue how much
but how much money did they make right
okay now you listen
rule of thumb of business take care of
your number ones and they don't take
care of the number ones listen the way i
judge you
you judge a uh man by the way he treats
his
wife who's a good wife you treat a you
judge a woman by the way
she treats her husband who's a good
husband who does his part who does her
part you
judge a parent by the way they treat you
judge who's a
kid that's doing his part you judge kids
based on how they take care of their mom
and dad who did their part i'm not going
to judge a kid whose
mom or dad is a deadbeat i'm not going
to sit there and tell but if a dad is
doing their part listen man you better
take care of this can you know what he
did for you
you know what you're you judge a great
business
based on how they treat their superstars
not stars yes stars but superstars
nba takes care of lebron james as much
as i disagree
it's their job mlb takes care of this
new guy
who is the first time all-star both
sides
they take care of the mike trout they
take care of you
and why not mr olympia
it's the only sport that i see that they
don't take care of the number one that's
not a good look
the last thing you want is one of the
greatest sports sportsman's ever in your
sport to even
remotely be talking trash about your
sport i'm not saying that's what you're
doing i mean no i want i want
that one but i'm telling you what i am
saying is
i want all athletes men women all
categories to be able to say i'm a pro
and i make a
pretty good living yeah all pros if
you're top 10 in the world at anything i
think you should still be able to
motivate the number of absolutely 100
percent out there
let me be the next phil heath not the
person anyways let's let's set it up
most i ever made in the minor leagues
most i ever made was two thousand
dollars a month
and they and that was what 10 years ago
you were hitting diggers i could hit a
little bit
the baltimore freaking orioles their
double
a team most of those guys are are
a back spasm away from the big leagues
they didn't
put them up in housing these guys are
still making 1900 bucks
and they defaulted on the team housing
these guys were sleeping
in their cars to play minor league
baseball
you understand what i'm saying now
people don't want college athletes to
get paid
people don't want in baseball just to go
back to what we're saying
if you don't if you don't get drafted
out of high school or if you decide to
go to college yeah you're not eligible
for three years same nfl rule
then whatever team drafts you which by
the way don't even get me started on the
draft the draft is the most evil thing
in the world on all sports we make a
spectacle out of it the draft is evil
it's an evil thing in every sport that
you don't get to choose who you play for
and your entire brand is dependent on
being picked by somebody that knows what
to do with you and your career
we call these guys busts these guys
aren't bus they're victims
most of them but not that sometimes by
the way and that's why the baltimore
orioles the last time they won a world
series was 83. three years of college
okay five years in the minors before
you're a free agent eight
years before you have any autonomy over
your career
imagine you coming out imagine you
coming out in any other industry
in any other industry you want to be a
financial advisor you want to be a
computer engineer and microsoft says
nah you got to come work for us and this
is what you have to make
and you don't get to decide anything
about it for five years and if you have
a problem with it well there's
somebody that wants to be a computer
engineer show your gratitude be grateful
and then they wonder why these guys milk
every single penny fans want them to get
their guys to give them a hometown
discount sorry brah
every single dollar whoever wants me i
get
the entire game is getting to the second
contract and then that's that
that's that man if you get to the second
contract the same thing with guys guys
who who would do whatever they had to do
guys who juiced a guy and everybody was
like these guys are cheaters
i never felt bad about those guys even
once matter of fact i was like you know
what good for them i didn't have the
balls to do it
i was afraid that if i got caught
juicing they'd go back to all my college
stats they'd be like this guy's been
juicing since college all those records
that's garbage
player of the year garbage it's all it's
all been and i so i never did it because
i was worried about legacy instead of
worrying about getting that kind of
by the way that's another conversation
that i would i would address that
conversation
front and center legalize juicing
listen and let me explain to what i mean
by legal not because it's legal already
anyways it's not people want to get
their hands on it
they're going to be able to get their
hands on it but if you're talking about
legalizing the whole libertarian
argument
you want to use it use it you think it
makes you better like
youth chad nichols said it best he said
look i can use everything and anything
out there i'm still not going to win mr
olympia
okay some people think just because you
take stuff you're going to go out there
and win
you think just because you take steroids
you're going to be able to hit 74
bombers
i dare you to do it go do it go be
basically saying do what you want with
your body no matter what whatever the
point i'm trying to drug it doesn't
necessarily help in all sports
you know in some sports if you don't do
it you're going to destroy yourself and
football like you don't think guys
you don't think lebron's using gh you
you seriously look at that
physique and you don't think the
allegation there patrick
wait a minute though do you actually
think a guy at that level who's saying i
spend one and a half million dollars
taking care of my body every year you
don't think he is
using i think a 265 pound man who
somehow has gained muscle mass
over 20 years while he runs five miles a
night and has a receding hairline has
taken steroids yeah
no it doesn't make my way you got to go
after his hairline bro let's stick to
the facts here
but here's the point of that by the way
the point obviously
the point i'm trying to make to you is
my argument today a lot of people are
looking to say
did pat just say legalize steroids
bro prohibition marijuana what else you
want to go with
okay gambling casinos was illegal people
said there's no way you know what's
going to be attracted to casinos
you ever been to all this stuff that
you're talking about
it's let the man make a choice if it
makes you
better and you got the advanta
competitive advantage but if i can use
it and you can use it hey
it's illegal but if i can't no problem
right now it's just incentivizing people
that are willing to break the rules
and that's the part like sammy said
something you want to take take the guns
away from good people
i will always have guns he says i sammy
the bull gravano will always have a gun
take it away from us i'll always have it
i want to transition to carlos mancia i
think what you're saying is
let the man choose choice what are your
thoughts on it though real quick
are you talking like he's straight up on
gh and everything i mean i do like
what i do i just think people should be
able to hey
we got 19 minutes to three stories joe
rogan a canceled culture critic called
that by carlos mencia for canceling him
the rap news it is ironic that a guy who
is now saying you shouldn't cancel
anybody at least started
the building of his podcast by canceling
me comedian carlos mancia says
in 2007 rogan stepped on the comedy
store stage to confront carlos mencia
about
allegations of the latter stealing jokes
from other comedians and from the club
audience
brian redman rogan's friend and eventual
podcast co-host filmed the incident
initially rogan suffered according to
the new york times
the comedy store banned rogan from the
club and the comedian's agency dropped
him however according to the article
rogen has posted
the clips online and had edited them
together with the footage of mencia
performing jokes alongside with other
comedians telling similar versions of
the jokes the video went viral
ruining mencia's career and reputation
more and more
with each click i had mencia on i
interviewed and we sat down and i told
him i said why don't you go out there
and go
put a tweet out and say do you think i
should go on joe rogan joe rogan why
don't we do it
the interview was done i think a year
and a half ago two years ago maybe
never happened hasn't happened till
today and he keeps going back to the
same place
you both are in this world this is your
space what do you say about what carlos
is saying i'm going to go to you first
okay well you know my opinion because we
had a conversation right so
listen first of all let's let's discuss
what canceled culture is
cancel culture is not calling out
somebody
for deplorable behavior cancel culture
is trying to bully society
into a belief system cancel culture is
can't it's actually this
actually this thing called cultural
hegemony it comes from the frankfurt
school it's it's antonio gramski
there's a real thing that cancel culture
is and it's trying it
the idea is to destabilize any sort of
opposition
to marxist ideas so that's what the
quote-unquote cancel culture is it's
cultural hegemony
all right having an opinion on somebody
doing something awful is not cancel
culture
so one ned furnace who uh is
carlos mencia's real name is trying to
use this term cancel culture which is a
legitimately
in my opinion evil political tool it's a
manipulation tool it's gaslighting
it's it's cultural bullying all right
it's a witch hunt
that is here to shut up opposition to
political
ideals that's what canceled culture is
being called out
for stealing ari shaffer and bobby lee's
material
when you are the biggest act in the
world by somebody who
who doesn't have the clout that you have
is balls
joe rogan had balls what joe rogan did
is he put his entire career on the line
people may not know this now
joe rogan was on a down swing in his
career they had tried to transfer
uh they tried to transform into a movie
star and he bombed he didn't make the
transition
from tv to the movies he bombed ufc
hadn't started yet
and his he hadn't reinvented himself as
this you know he was doing fear factor
he was doing news radio and he wasn't
yeah after after news radio he did fear
factor he hated fear factor so he left
fear factor wanted to do movies the
movies bombed
he's going early at the comedy store
i've played the comedy store if
people don't know it it's the mecca of
comedy it's unbelievable
playing any rooms there it's just such
an awesome thing to be a part of it so
it's like getting in that bad at yankee
stadium right
carlos mancia closed the place out every
night he was the biggest act in the
world
he's the guy comedy central gave the
chappelle show to
right okay they he so what imagine
a nobody comic all right i'm trying to
think of something that would make sense
today
for people that don't know what happened
it would be like i don't know
like um it would be like andy dick
almost
walking on stage to dave chappelle and
calling out dave chappelle for stealing
other people's material
because the other people were like what
am i supposed to do is dave chappelle
nobody's going to believe me
and that's what men see it did because
not only did men see us steal the
material
but then he had the people whose
material he was stealing
fired he had them taken off the stage at
the store so it wasn't enough that he
took their act
he then killed their career this dude is
like it's about as evil as you could be
in the comedy industry
now his whole point is well people did
this for years people people always did
this robin williams stole jokes
right but we didn't have the we didn't
have the material on tape
we didn't have the material on tape this
is something that white comics were
accused of stealing black comic stuff
for years they were accused of stealing
like red fox richard pryor would talk
about it
and uh um who just died uh paul mooney
would talk about this all the time at
caroline's you'd say like
this joke is xyz there's there is
parallel thinking which is a real thing
there's only so many jokes there's only
so many premises all right and how you
put those two things together is yours
your material is yours and there's a lot
of crossover in comedy there's only
seven stories
this man was stealing people's stuff
this is no different than this guy
coming in this is our work
my material is my work it's your
currency it's your words or your
currency if you had
an auto dealership and then the biggest
auto dealership in the world came and
just took your cars and you're just
supposed to be like i don't know what am
i supposed to do no you have to you have
to be like bro
what rogan did was valiant it was not
cancel culture and the fact that he's he
he is still this many years later trying
to equate those two things
tells you exactly who this person is of
course he's going to use the word cancer
culture because that's you know the word
right now but basically he got exposed
he got exposed yeah exposed is the word
that happened absolutely you were doing
something wrong
and someone said had the balls like you
said to be like i don't know about all
this
because you saw what happened to rogan
his agency fired up yeah he got kicked
off gigs he wasn't doing anything more
and then he put the clips out there and
people were like you know what rogan was
actually right here
he exposed him it's not any different
than like what ed
edward snowden did for the nsa and he
exposed what al was going on
yeah so you know you you run the
uh the run the risk of getting
literally like rogan could have got
canceled he was canceled by his agency
exactly he was cancelled the ironic part
is that he exposed
ned or or carlos however you want to
call him and
the market took over and said no we're
actually with joe rogan on this this
actually goes back to what pat said
earlier about
how bad ideas that's exactly by the way
kai greene is watching a podcast he just
joined us kai i got a simple question
for you man are you competing in 2021
mr olympia and if you missed some of the
ideas i had a few minutes ago and you
watch this uh
rerun of the podcast go to hour 25 hour
23 and watch it for a few minutes by the
way
if you can call him now we'll get him on
if he wants to call you we'll we'll dial
him in wow but but i just texted carlos
mencia
okay and just now all right just right
there i just texted carlos mancia so
if if you're watching this if you're
watching this
carlos i want to bring you back and
let's sit down on the podcast
and let's talk about this it's been a
couple years here's
here's what i'm a big fan of and this
there's opportunities in
life because to me if you were to name a
country the greatest country in the
world for redemption what would you say
is the greatest usa baby
greatest country in the world this is
the comeback and by the way
is it fair to say that all of us need
that are grateful the fact that there is
this concept of redemption in this great
country
everybody at this point everybody
okay so i'm all for redemption but the
part that
is frustrating is not capitalizing on
the opportunities you have
to redeem yourself and you keep being
authentic
you keep digging so folks if you're
watching this if you'd like to see
carlos come on
i've interviewed carlos mitchell on the
valuetainment channel if you haven't
found if you go type in valuetainment
and david and mencia you'll see the
interview it's pretty entertaining to
watch probably one of my favorite
interviews
uh you'll see a lot of there but
if you'd like to see carlos join us on
the podcast not interview
send them a tweet hashtag pbd by david
and i'll uh let's
let's if other people want to see that
we'll invite them if this is something
that you would be interested to see
carlos come here
tell us on twitter if not totally get it
but if you do go on twitter and let us
know
for if you want to see me any young
comics that are watching if there are
any young comics or anybody
wanting to be a comic okay this is
something lenny marcus told me lenny
marcus if you don't know who he is very
very very very funny funny funny comic
he's a 25-year vet he's a curmudgeon uh
name dropping i was at uh stand-up new
york doing a show with him and todd
barry who's got a stadium tour now one
of the funniest dudes of all time and
they both said the same thing cost 25
bucks
copyright your jokes because one of the
bigger things that happens one of the
biggest i'm actually going to ask you
that if that's even possible copyright
your jokes and one of the biggest thing
that happens is
isn't what carlos has been said carlos
mencia the biggest thing with carlos
mencia is that
he it wasn't that he stole the jokes
it's that he tried to ruin these guys
career
instead of being like bro i'll give you
a writing credit and i'll elevate you
look what do you need you need 500 bucks
here's 500 bucks all right and a writing
credit
i need this joke all right i'm rich now
rich people aren't funny
i don't connect with the common man
anymore people aren't funny
all right here's the deal this is what
you got elon musk is pretty funny
no they they are funny soundfield's
going to have a bone to pick with you
they're holding
what they're they're very funny i'm just
saying that that's the that's the idea
the idea
that comics have especially when they've
come from the streets is that once i
make it that's right no longer yeah
that's why jimmy fox always has like
some leaky faucet in his house yeah
something that like the every man he's
like i don't want my house to be perfect
well ellen i want some
weird [ __ ] smoke protector beeping
exactly ellen's last special she
addressed it and it was perfect she was
like they said you're a billion you're a
billionaire you're a billionaire with a
daytime show you can't
you can't uh identify with the common
person anymore and i told my butler that
was ridiculous
like it was a great line you know just
that's why pbd always has a broken tv in
his house he keeps a big crack in the
middle of his tv
but the bigger thing than what carlos
mancia did it's a huge huge problem in
new york
is advertising agencies will go to a
comedy show and there'll be these people
who work in marketing and they'll be
copywriters
and they'll see a joke and be like wow
that's going to be great on state farm
and they will just completely steal a
bit and it'll wind up in a commercial
but if you're watching copyright if
you're watching this and you'd like to
see
carlos mencia join us on the podcast
smash thumbs up and subscribe to our
podcast this is not valuetainment this
is a complete different channel that we
have
subscribe and click on that notification
because many people tell me when
when we go live they don't get
notifications make sure you do that last
story before we wrap
up last story before we wrap up boy
scouts reach 850 million dollar
settlement with tens of thousands of
sexual abuse victims this is an nbc news
story
tens of thousands of people who say they
were sexually abused while scouts and
filed suits against the boy scouts of
america have reached an 850 million
dollar settlement
the largest in a child sexual abuse case
in united states history more than 84
000 people were part of a lawsuit
against a 110 year old organization
which has been plagued with claims
of abuse from volunteers and leaders
since the 1960 the boy scouts of america
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy last
year and its faces mounting legal costs
for defendants
self against claims of sexual abuse
against boys boy scouts leadership has
insisted that scouting
is safer now than ever before ninety
percent of claims against the
organization accord more than 30 years
ago okay
thoughts since you were part of it what
do you have to say about no man it's a
shame
it's such a shame because the the boy
scouts was a lot of fun and it's
something that
you know we should all be learning we
should be learning these survival skills
we should be learning camping we should
be learning this stuff
and community is so important man and i
feel similar to the catholic church i
grew up catholic
and my whole family's still catholic and
i just it was
look man it was an unforgivable it was
an unforgivable thing for me what
happened with the catholic church it was
unforgivable
their response to it and now it's coming
out with
it's very obvious that this has been a
problem for decades decades
that they've been trying to hide and it
it's the cover-up is worse than the
crime man like
you know the the if there's a pedo if
there's pedophiles in your ranks root
them out and be obvious about and say we
found this
we apologize my god it can't get worse
than this and we're gonna do everything
we possibly can do to make sure that
that we're not fostering an environment
for these people in the future
but instead like paying people to go
away and spending 30 years trying to
cover this stuff up and like who's
trying to jail
dude who's going to freaking jail not
one freaking face
i go online i look this up not one
effing guy and
go online look this up people um
they're putting like a cap on when you
can come out with your story as well
so like if you meet don't hit that
deadline stop
your limitations right and then my
question
you had like you run people dude you
know with the insurance
how are they going to survive with the
liability insurance moving forward
because i would assume that like that
money is uh
not coming yeah you know to these people
i mean i would be very surprised but
i mean anyone that has been abused i
mean yeah money
i guess that'll help but not really oh
yeah you need convictions man like we
need to see
like mother efforts going to jail dude
like
not one person that i read about is like
oh yeah this person is
held accountable i think we need
accountability in this world
that that's a good point but here's what
i will say do you have any comments on
this or no i mean i've got a lot of
comments on this because
go forward look i i was never part of
the boy scouts
uh i remember it's it's ironic here that
says
it's occurred more than 30 years ago i
remember being 10 years old i'm 40
and 10 years ago i get brought out in
the middle of summer
uh summer camp boy scout camp one day my
buddy one of my best friends is like oh
we're gonna be at boy scouts
i got out there and you just want
something you know it just doesn't feel
right
i'm out there it's sweaty as hell people
are talking about sleeping in tents
i'm good i'm out yeah some weird [ __ ]
was happening i just felt it i just
i said you know what i'm gonna go play
some ball play some football basketball
the boy scouts always felt weird to me i
don't know i don't know how you made it
out alive between being boy scouts in
the catholic church
thank god that you're not i was a i was
a chubby kid i wasn't very popular
you weren't a hot kid bro you always
wondered why not me
yeah why not me but you know short clip
short clip
you didn't have what it took when you
were 10 years old it's been nice being
on this podcast but i'll never be able
to
pair it again sorry bro i just the boy
scouts to me always felt creepy and
weird
and sleepovers and it just validates
like the weirdness that was going on
tens of thousands of kids were molested
this is like a worse cover from the
it was the worst american worst kept
secret ridiculous you used to make fun
of this on family yeah
on family movers intense and this is
acceptable yeah dude this is so
beyond the road and i get that there's
good parts of it you know you learn no
no no no no no no no no no no no no dude
look
out i'm disappointed i'm disappointed
but i am in no
way defending them and this is my own
family my own family
i've we we've just had you can't talk
about it anymore i i was raised very
strict irish catholic
and it's like that's their immediate
go-to well the good outweighs the bad
the catholic church does more good i'm
like
no absolutely not that's not what we're
doing here
we're not justifying we're not
equivocating no no this is bad
and there's there's no answer for the
bad yeah except to get rid of them
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question
memberships have declined 61 since 2019.
let me say that one more time 61 percent
they tried to open it up to girls that
was their response like
five didn't three years ago they try to
open it up to women here's the question
for you here's the question for you
so so take so at this point are these
guys going to make it or no no
okay so let's just say boys cats goes
what happens with the girl scouts i want
to know anyway hear me by the girl scout
that's a whole different business model
that we'll talk about here
but say they go out of business they're
done okay what do you send your boys to
to go learn how to you know learn the
principles of what it is to
there's a lot of our kids i went to boy
scouts uh what do you call it uh
uh with t-con dylan when they said oh
you need if they sleep over for this
many nights they get a badge i said i
really don't give a [ __ ] about the badge
yeah
i'm not doing no sleepover with this
they're going to be sleeping over on my
house
but they got to meet michael jackson but
we went and we shot they shot right
they shot rifles they shot a few
different things it was like slingshots
it was actually a good experience
i enjoyed it for the day that i was with
them
so accountability is on a few different
things there's a level of accountability
on the people that took advantage
there's a level of accountability on the
parents that we're not watching and
saying hey just go out there and like
the kid
the guy that was giving you his son for
three hours a day and you're teaching
them how to hit the baseball
yeah i'm just pretty pretty much a
glorified expensive babysitter is what
you were right so the parents are like
ah you know whatever go do whatever you
wanna do my kids
there's a level of accountability on the
parents right there so organization
leadership at the top is where it goes
because you look if it's eighty four
thousand it's not like it's 22 yeah
like it's 88 it's 84 000 cases we're
talking about now here's the other part
check this out
members of the boy scouts over the year
buzz aldrin
neil armstrong neil armstrong bill gates
hank aaron willie banks
josh hart michael jordan d michael
jordan tommy lasorda
uh nolan ryan mark spitz steve
young uh the list goes on by martin
luther king
jr d mlk jon bon jovi jimmy buffett
harrison ford zach galifianakis that's
where they screwed up
okay so you got andy griffith okay jay
leno okay
this thing i can go on by chris pratt
and mike rowe
steven spielberg jimmy stewart john
wayne michael bloomberg okay george
w bush clinton gerard ford
john f kennedy ross perot jeff sessions
i can go on and on and on and on
communities in self preservation
good things that they were teaching i
had a guy that i work in the insurance
industry was and eagle scouts he tells
me go go meet an eagles guest
hire them free cops higher eagle scouts
if you can find them
the problem with this is this is such
terrible 61 since 2019
yeah to do that that is not good i have
an easy solution
no sleepovers do your stuff during the
day
do your your shooting what do you do do
you you know help help old ladies
crosstalk street you think no please
don't get touched during the day though
it's the pareto principle right
i don't know who it was but they said
the freaks come out at night first of
all i think that was
the sergeant in the army once told me
hey rule of thumb
never have a girl in your barracks from
the army without another person watching
where it's just like
the door's always gotta be open just
don't do it
because one of our guys came out and
this girl came out he didn't want to be
with her he just
she came out and she said you know he
took advantage of me
he's like dude i promise you i was just
sitting there with him because he had no
interest in her
she later on says nothing ever happened
i just he lost rank
yeah nothing ever happened so i think
there's a part of it where
the only way they can do sleepover is if
a parent accompanies them if not we're
not doing it there's
certain systems you can do all i'm
saying is
there's still you got to still have it
like this whole thing with lawsuits
where kids were falling off of
uh at parks and breaking bones until
lawyers were suing them and then
cities started getting rid of their
parks and they got kids that can't not
play
there's negative ramifications to this
as well you definitely got to fire the
entire leadership team if you're going
to recreate you're huge on on predictive
analytics right like at some point we
have to start looking at these things
we have to start looking at these things
and say okay catholic church
boy scouts okay what what did they have
in common and what are we not
investigating right now do they need a
spokesperson pat
oh this is listen you got to bring
somebody oh yeah like an athlete like
someone look at what this is
who did houston astros bring houston
astros brought who we're so canceled
they brought they brought bobby bonds he
used to astros who did they bring to
help them out with their
uh uh uh bestie baker not bobby bond
they brought dusty pig
dusty baker came in it's like look i
understand what happened we got to clean
everybody likes dusty yeah so
you need a leader that comes in that
america
trust that america says okay let's see
what this person close it down rebrand
start over you kind of do need to do
that close it down
there's a lot of problems i agree with
you close it down hey brandon having not
the boy scouts
said that we've gone for two hours it's
been a fun podcast we've covered a lot
of different stories
and uh we are we doing it again thursday
or no podcast this thursday because
we're out of town so this thursday no
podcast but
we'll be back we'll be back next week
yes we didn't get any azalea man
oh we didn't but you know i got to go
and jump on the zoom here but we can do
that next week but we will
we got dude i got five other stories i
haven't gotten into we'll definitely we
need to make this eventually three hours
we're not there yet right now though
having said that folks have a great week
and we will do this again next week take
care everybody bye